WHEN POSSIBLE.
AND >> Chris: REPORTING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, DAVID,
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, TREASURY
SECRETARY STEVEN MNUCHIN.
MR. SECRETARY, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
GREAT TO BE BACK WITH YOU.
>> Chris: THE OFFICIAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AS WE JUST
REPORTED FOR APRIL IS 14.7%.
BUT THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
7 MILLION JOBS LOST SINCE APRIL
APRIL 18TH, OR THE MILLIONS OF
WORKERS NOT LOOKING FOR JOBS OR
WHAT ARE CALLED THE
UNDEREMPLOYED.
SO MR. SECRETARY, WHAT IS THE
REAL UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS WE TALK TODAY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
THE REAL ISSUE, AND THE
PRESIDENT AND I UNDERSTAND THIS,
IS THE ECONOMIC ISSUES THAT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND AMERICAN
BUSINESS ARE FACING AS A RESULT
OF THIS VIRUS AND THE DECISION
TO CLOSE THE ECONOMY, AND THAT’S
THE REASON WHY THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO WORK WITH THE STATES TO
SAFELY REOPEN THE ECONOMY SO WE
CAN SAFELY GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK.
SO THESE ARE VERY, VERY LARGE
NUMBERS, THESE ARE NOT LARGE
NUMBERS BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMY
WASN’T DOING WELL, THESE ARE
LARGE NUMBERS BECAUSE WE CHECKED
ON THE ECONOMY AND I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE BIGGEST COMPONENT
OF THIS WAS IN TRAVEL AND RETAIL
AND LEISURE AND NOT A SURPRISE,
WE CLOSED DOWN MAJOR PARTS OF
THE ECONOMY.
>> Chris: I’M GOING TO GET
INTO THAT WITH YOU IN A MOMENT,
BUT I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT THAT
WE FACE WITH THE REAL NUMBERS
ARE SOME OF THE BUREAU OF OUR
LABOR STATISTICS SAYS WHAT THEY
CALL THE REAL UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBER FOR APRIL, WHICH AGAIN
INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR WORK OR
UNDEREMPLOYED, IS 22.8%, BUT
AGAIN THAT IS NOT A CLUE --
BECAUSE THE UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBER
STOPPED IN MID-APRIL, DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE 7 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS SINCE THEN.
ARE WE TALKING CLOSE TO 25% AT
THIS POINT, WHICH IS
GREAT DEPRESSION LEVELS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WE COULD
BE BUT LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE,
UNLIKE THE GREAT DEPRESSION
WHERE YOUR ECONOMIC ISSUES THAT
LED TO THIS, WE CLOSED DOWN THE
ECONOMY, SO WOULDN’T BE A
SURPRISE IF YOU CLOSED DOWN THE
ECONOMY THAT IN HALF OF THE
WORKFORCE, HALF THE PEOPLE
DIDN’T WORK.
AND THAT’S WHY WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON REBUILDING THIS
ECONOMY AND GETTING IT BACK TO
WHERE IT WAS.
THIS IS NO FAULT OF AMERICAN
BUSINESSES, THIS IS NO FAULT OF
AMERICAN WORKERS, THIS IS THE
RESULT OF THE VIRUS AND THAT’S
WHERE THE PRESIDENT AND I, WE
ARE DETERMINED TO PUT TOGETHER
THE LARGEST ECONOMIC PROGRAM
EVER TO HELP AMERICAN WORKERS
GET THROUGH THIS.
SO YOU ARE CORRECT, THE REPORTED
NUMBERS ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
GET WORSE BEFORE THEY GET
BETTER, BUT THAT’S WHERE WE ARE
FOCUSED ON REBUILDING THIS
ECONOMY.
WE WILL HAVE A BETTER THIRD
QUARTER, A BETTER FOURTH QUARTER
AND NEXT YEAR IS GOING TO BE A
GREAT YEAR.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THAT, BECAUSE YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT BOTH SAY THE ECONOMY
IS GOING TO COME ROARING BACK,
BUT I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, AND I
WANT TO ASK ABOUT A NUMBER OF
SIGNS WHICH INDICATE THAT THE
RECOVERY IS GOING TO BE MUCH
LOWER THAN THAT, SIR.
JOB LOSSES ARE NOT JUST IN
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY, AIRLINES,
RESTAURANTS, AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT, BUT THEY’RE MORE
WIDESPREAD.
THE WHITE COLLAR AND GOVERNMENT
SECTOR, 3 MILLION JOBS LOST.
MAJOR RETAILERS LIKE NEIMAN
MARCUS AND J.CREW DECLARING
BANKRUPTCY AND THE NONPARTISAN
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE SAYS
UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE END NOT OF
THIS YEAR, BUT OF 2021 WILL
STILL BE 9.5%.
QUESTION, ARE YOUR ROSY
PREDICTIONS BASED ON ECONOMIC
REALITY OR THE NOVEMBER ELECTION
ELECTION?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE FIRST OF
ALL, THESE NUMBERS IMPACT REAL
PEOPLE AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE,
WE UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS
IMPACTING REAL PEOPLE, SO
THEY’RE NOT JUST NUMBERS.
IT’S IMPACTING REAL PEOPLE.
MY NUMBERS AREN’T ROSY.
WHAT I SAID IS YOU’RE GOING TO
HAVE A VERY, VERY BAD
SECOND QUARTER AND THEN I THINK
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE A BOUNCE
BACK FROM A LOW STANDPOINT.
NONE OF THE ECONOMIC MODELS HAVE
EVER WORKED IN PREDICTING WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU CLOSE DOWN DUE
TO MEDICAL REASONS.
SO MY PREDICTIONS ARE BASED UPON
WHAT I SEE AS THE RATE OF
REOPENING, AND A CAREFUL WAY,
WHICH ALSO BRINGS THE BLOOD BUT
IF YOU -- I’VE ALSO HEARD FROM
ANY DOCTORS THAT HAVE VACCINES
IN TRIALS AND THEIR EXPECTATIONS
OF BEING ABLE TO GET A VACCINE
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR AND
HAVING REAL VIRAL TREATMENTS,
THE ADVENT OF TESTING, ALL THESE
THINGS ARE GOING TO HELP GIVE
AMERICAN BUSINESS AND AMERICAN
WORKERS THE CONFIDENCE TO REOPEN
IN A CAREFUL AND DELIBERATE WAY.
>> Chris: AND WHAT ABOUT THE
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN THAT FARMERS
AND PROCESSORS SAY IS BROKEN,
BECAUSE THEY CAN’T GET THEIR
MEAT AND THEY CAN’T GET THEIR
PRODUCE FROM THE FIELD TO
MARKET?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
CHRIS, THOSE ARE REAL ISSUES BUT
AGAIN, IT WILL BE EMPHASIZED I
SEE THE GLASS AS HALF-FULL AND
NOT HALF-EMPTY.
IF YOU WERE TOLD THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WE WOULD VIRTUALLY SHUT
DOWN THE ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAINS
AND STILL BE ABLE TO FEED
AMERICA AND GET DRUGS TO AMERICA
AND CONTINUE TO DO CRITICAL
WORK, I COULDN’T BE MORE PLEASED
HOW AMERICANS ARE PULLING
TOGETHER TO GET THROUGH THIS.
SO YES, THERE ARE ISSUES, WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE ISSUES.
THE TASK FORCE IS FOCUSING ON
THOSE ISSUES WHEN WE SEE THEM.
WE’RE FIGURING OUT HOW TO FIX
THEM.
>> Chris: AND NOW THE
PRESIDENT IS CALLING FOR STATES
TO REOPEN AND A NUMBER OF
GOVERNORS ARE AROUND THE
COUNTRY, BUT THIS WEEK THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE COST OF THAT, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WILL SOME PEOPLE BE AFFECTED?
YES.
WILL SOME PEOPLE BE AFFECTED
BADLY?
YES, BUT WE HAVE TO GET OUR
COUNTRY OPEN AND WE HAVE TO GET
IT OPEN SOON.
>> Chris: BUT, PATRICK PARKER,
HEAD OF THE PHILADELPHIA
FEDERAL RESERVE SAYS IF ECONOMY
OPENS TOO TOO SOON IN THE VIRUS
STRIKES AGAIN, "NOT ONLY WOULD
THIS BE A HEALTH CATASTROPHE BUT
IT WOULD REVERSE THE RECOVERY AS
WELL," IF THAT HAPPENS, HE
PREDICTS, -- SHUTDOWNS ARE
REINTRODUCED.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THERE IS A
CONSIDERABLE RISK -- NOT TO SAY
YOU SHOULDN’T DO IT -- BUT THERE
IS A CONSIDERABLE RISK OF
REOPENING BOTH FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND AN ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
IF WE DO THIS CAREFULLY WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNORS, I DON’T
THINK THERE’S A CONSIDERABLE
RISK.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I THINK
THERE’S A CONSIDERABLE RISK OF
NOT REOPENING.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT WOULD
BE PERMANENT ECONOMIC DAMAGE TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND WE ARE
GOING TO REOPEN IN A VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY THAT GETS PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK SAFELY, THAT HAS
THEM SOCIAL DISTANCE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE’VE SEEN,
CHRIS, IS A LOT OF BUSINESSES
CAN DO TELEWORK.
NOT EVER BUT HE HAS TO COME BACK
INTO THE OFFICE AT THE SAME
TIME, BUT PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
GO INTO STORES.
SOME OF THEM WILL HAVE
RESERVATIONS WHEN THEY GO IN,
BUT BUSINESSES WILL BE ABLE TO
REOPEN AND I THINK AS YOU KNOW,
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY HAD
VERY DEVASTATING IMPACTS, LIKE
NEW YORK AND CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY DIDN’T.
AND THIS IS ALL BEING MONITORED
VERY, VERY CAREFULLY.
>> Chris: LET’S TURN TO THE
QUESTION OF WHAT THAT -- IF
THERE’S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
RESPONSE FROM WASHINGTON AND IF
SO, WHAT IT’S GOING TO BE.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI SAID
SHE MAY INTRODUCE A PHASE FOR
RELIEF BILL THIS WEEK.
BUT LARRY KUDLOW, THE
WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR
SAID THIS WEEK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO WAIT
UNTIL LATE MAY OR EARLY JUNE TO
DECIDE WHERE TO GO NEXT ENTERS
THE PRESIDENT ON THAT SUBJECT
THIS WEEK.
>> WE ARE IN NO RUSH.
IT WE ARE IN NO RUSH.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DO WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DO, BUT I WOULD SAY
WE ARE NOT LOOKING -- WE WANT TO
SEE WHAT THEY HAVE, BUT I CAN’T
SAY THAT WE ARE IN A RUSH.
WE WERE IN A RUSH TO GET THE
MONEY OUT TO PEOPLE, WE HAVE
GOTTEN THE MONEY OUT.
>> Chris: QUESTION, WITH
33 MILLION PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED,
WITH THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM MONEY RUNNING OUT BY THE
END OF THIS MONTH, WITH STATE
BUDGETS CRATERING, THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS IN NO RUSH?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
THE PRESIDENT OUT AND I HAVE
BEEN VERY CLEAR ON THIS AND WE
ARE IN 100% AGREEMENT.
FIRST, LET ME JUST SAY WE
APPRECIATE THE ENORMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT BOTH
PARTIES IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE WORK TOGETHER TO GET AN
UNPRECEDENTED RESPONSE.
YOU’RE TALKING OVER $3 TRILLION
INTO THE ECONOMY, YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT ANOTHER TWO AND A HALF-
HALF-$5 TRILLION WORKING WITH
THE FEDERAL RESERVE.
THIS IS NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE AND
THINK THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND I ARE NOW
SAYING IS WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY.
A LOT OF THIS MONEY IS NOT EVEN
INTO THE ECONOMY YET.
LET’S TAKE THE NEXT FEW WEEKS,
I’M HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
REPUBLICANS AND THE DEMOCRATS TO
UNDERSTAND THESE ISSUES.
THE PRESIDENT AND I ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUTSIDE
PEOPLE, WITH BUSINESS.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
BEFORE WE JUMP AGAIN AND SPENT
ANOTHER FEW TRILLION OF
TAXPAYERS MONEY THAT WE DO IT
CAREFULLY.
WE HAD AN EMERGENCY PROCESS.
IT WORKED QUICKLY.
WE ARE THERE TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO BE
CONSIDERATE AND IF WE NEED TO
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS, AS I SAID
BEFORE, WE ARE WILLING TO SPEND
WHATEVER IT TAKES, BUT WHATEVER
IT TAKES NEED TO BE DONE
CAREFULLY.
>> Chris: I’VE GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE LEFT AND I WANT TO
SQUEEZE THIS IN.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE WON’T
SIGN ANOTHER RELIEF BILL WITHOUT
A PAYROLL TAX CUT IN IT, BUT
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND A LOT OF TOP
REPUBLICANS ARE EXPRESSING GREAT
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THEY
SAY A PAYROLL TAX CUT DOESN’T
HELP IF SOMEBODY’S UNEMPLOYED
AND THEY’RE NOT ON THE PAYROLL.
AND HERE’S WHAT THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
>> I THINK I CAN SAFELY SAY FOR
OUR TEAM HERE, THE REPUBLICAN
SENATE -- MAJORITY -- IF THERE’S
ANY REDLINE, IT’S ON LITIGATION.
>> Chris: LITIGATION OF COURSE
MEANS LIABILITY PROTECTION THAT
IF SOMEBODY GOES BACK TO WORK OR
GOES INTO A RESTAURANT, THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SUE TO SAY
THAT THEY GOT THE VIRUS FROM
THAT PLACE.
SO GIVEN THE HESITANCY FROM THE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL, WILL THE
PRESIDENT, WILL YOU INSIST THAT
A PAYROLL TAX CUT BE PART OF THE
NEXT RELEASE BILL?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY PUSHING FOR THE
PAYROLL TAX CUT.
IT’S AN INCENTIVE TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
IT’S DELIVERING MONEY TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC AND TO BUSINESS.
IN A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY AND THAT
WILL BE ONE OF THE COMPONENTS --
YOU’VE HEARD OF
MITCH McCONNELL TALK ABOUT
LIABILITY, WE HAVE AGREE WITH
THAT COMPLETELY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN ASKING
FOR MORE MONEY FOR STATES.
WE’VE BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DO THINGS JUST
TO BAILOUT STATES THAT WERE
POORLY MANAGED, BUT WE ARE GOING
TO LOOK AT ALL THESE ISSUES AND
LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE, ALL THESE
BILLS HAVE HAD ENORMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WHEN WE NEED TO GO BACK AND WORK
AND HELP THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, WE
WILL DO THIS IN A BIPARTISAN WAY
AND MAKE SURE WE GET ALL OF
THESE THINGS INCLUDED.
>> Chris: SECRETARY,